MICHALE FEE: Today we're
going to continue developing
our equivalent circuit model,
the Hodgkin-Huxley model
of a neuron.
And we're still focusing
on the mechanism
that generates spikes.
As you recall, there
are two conductances,
iron conductances, that lead
to action potential generation.
There is sodium
conductance that is
connected to a sodium battery
that has a high equilibrium
potential.
There is a potassium
conductance that
is connected to a
potassium battery that
has a negative
equilibrium potential,
and those two
conductances together
have voltage and
time dependence that
lead to the generation
of a positive going,
followed by a negative going,
fluctuation in the voltage that
is the action potential.
And as you recall,
the way that happens,
there is a time dependence
to these conductances
so that when the sodium
conductance turns on,
this resistor gets really
small, and basically connects
the inside of the cell
to that positive battery.
When the sodium
conductance turns off
and the potassium
conductance turns on,
we're disconnecting
the sodium battery
and connecting the
potassium battery,
which has a negative voltage.
And the voltage
of the cell, then,
is driven toward the negative
potassium equilibrium
potential.
So last time we worked out the
voltage and time dependence
of the potassium conductance.
Today, we're going to focus
on the, sorry, focus here
on the sodium
conductance and explain
various aspects of the
voltage and time dependence
of the sodium conductance.
And then once we do
that, we're going
to turn in the second
half of the lecture
to a really beautiful, simple
model of a disease related
to a defect in the
sodium channel.
And it's an example of
how we can use modeling
to test and elaborate on
hypotheses about how defects
in a circuit, or
in an ion channel,
can lead to very complex
phenotypes in a whole animal.
So as you recall, our
Hodgkin-Huxley model
has three conductances
and a capacitance
that represents a capacitor
that represents the capacitance
of the membrane.
The total membrane
ionic current is just
a sum of the sodium current,
the potassium current,
and this voltage independent,
time independent,
fixed leak current.
So the equation for
the membrane potential,
the differential equation
for the membrane potential
in the Hodgkin-Huxley model,
is just a simple first order
linear differential
equation that
relates the membrane current
and the membrane potential.
So last time we described
a set of experiments
that were done by
Hodgkin and Huxley
to study the voltage
and time dependence
of these conductances
in the squid giant axon.
And as you remember,
this axon is very large.
It's 1 millimeter
in diameter, which
makes it very easy
to put wires into it,
and change the voltage, and
measure the currents, and so
on.
So the experiment they did was
a voltage clamp experiment,
where you can hyperpolarize
and depolarize the cell.
There's a very fast
feedback system
that allows you to
set a command voltage,
and this operational amplifier
injects however much current
is needed to hold the cell at
whatever membrane potential you
command.
And the typical experiment
that they would do
would be to hyperpolarize
or depolarize
the cell to fixed
membrane potentials
and measure how much current
passes through the membrane
during and after that transient
change in the command voltage.
So if you take a
squid giant axon,
you start at minus
65 millivolts,
and you hyperpolarize the
cell, not much happens.
And that's because
all of those currents
are already off when the cell
is hyperpolarize at minus 60
or at low voltages.
On the other hand, if you
start at minus 65 millivolts
and depolarize the cell up to 0
millivolts, all of a sudden you
see a very large
transient current
that first goes negative,
which corresponds
to positive charges going
into the cell followed
by a positive current
that's associated
with positive charges
leaving the cell.
And last time we
talked about how
we can dissect these two
phases of the current,
this negative phase and
this positive phase,
into two different
ionic conductances.
That they did that experiment
by replacing the sodium
in the extracellular
solution that the axon was
sitting in with a solution
that has no sodium in it.
They replaced that
with choline chloride.
So choline is a positive ionic--
has a positive charge
and chloride, of course,
has a negative charge.
And so you can replace
the sodium chloride
with choline chloride.
And now, when you
depolarize your cell,
you can see that that
negative part is gone.
And the only current you
see is this positive--
this kind of slowly ramping
up positive current.
And they identified that as
being due to potassium ions.
And if you subtract
the current curve
without sodium from the
current curve with sodium,
the difference is
obviously due to sodium.
And so if you plot the
difference between those two
curves, you can see that
the sodium current turns
on very rapidly and then
decays very rapidly,
that that transient
sodium current happens
very quickly, almost before
the potassium current even
gets started.
And we talked about how that
fast sodium current, followed
by a slower potassium current,
is exactly the profile,
that we showed here, that
generates depolarizing change
in the voltage followed
by a hyperpolarize change
in the voltage that looks
like an action potential.
So now, let's just
review quickly how
we took these current curves,
and from those, extracted
the conductance of the sodium
and potassium ion channels
as a function of
voltage and time.
So what we did was
we looked at the case
where we do our voltage
clamp experiment
to different voltages.
We start hyperpolarized.
We step up to minus 40 and
measure this potassium current.
We step up to 0, and you see
this larger potassium current.
If you step from
minus 40 to 40, you
see an even larger
potassium current.
And you can plot this peak
current, or the steady state
current, as a
function of voltage.
That gives you an I-V curve, and
we'll look at that in a second.
If you do the same thing
for the sodium currents,
you see something
different that's
initially very confusing.
If you step from
minus 80 to minus 40,
you see a small sodium current.
If you make a larger
voltage step up to 0,
you see this bigger
sodium current.
But then if you step up
from minus 80 millivolts
to 40 millivolts, now
you see you just have
a tiny little sodium current.
Anybody remember
why that would be?
Why is it that you would
see only a very tiny sodium
current, if you step
up to 40 millivolts?
What is the equilibrium
potential for sodium?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good, good.
So what would the
sodium current be
if I had stepped this voltage
up exactly to 50 millivolts?
AUDIENCE: 0.
MICHALE FEE: It'd be 0.
So this is pretty
close to 50 millivolts,
which is why the sodium current
is actually pretty small.
So now, let's plot
the peak current
as a function of voltage for
potassium and the peak current
here as a function of
voltage for sodium.
That's what that looks like.
So you can see
that the potassium
current is 0 for these
voltages down here and grows.
It's actually stay 0 for
even more negative voltages.
The sodium current,
on the other hand,
has this very kind
of funny shape.
It's linear up here
around high voltages,
around the sodium equilibrium
or reversal potential,
and then at drops to 0.
The sodium current stays
at 0 for negative voltages.
And you recall that we use
this to think about what
the conductance must be.
So let me just walk you
through that logic again.
So remember that the current
is just a conductance
times the driving potential.
The driving
potential is positive
when you're above the
equilibrium potential,
and it's negative
when you're below.
So this term here
is a straight line.
It's linear in voltage,
and it goes through 0
when V is equal to EK.
So there is the driving
potential for potassium
as a function of voltage.
Now, you can see clearly
that the conductance
as a function of voltage
has some voltage dependence,
because this doesn't
look like this.
So the difference
between this and this
is captured by this
voltage-dependent conductance.
And does anyone remember what
that conductance, that GK
as a function of V, looks like?
AUDIENCE: Sigmoidal.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, sigmoidal.
And what is it down here?
It's 0.
So the way that you
can get a 0 current,
even with a very negative
driving potential,
is if the conductance is 0.
You can see that the
current is linear up here,
and the driving potential
is linear up here.
So the conductance
has to be constant.
And so we have a
conductance that
has to be 0 down here and a
constant non-zero up here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So why is
the potassium curve
0 when it's more
negative than GK?
Why doesn't it go in
the other direction?
MICHALE FEE: Why doesn't
this curve do something else?
So what is it that you're--
AUDIENCE: Like why doesn't
it-- why doesn't it--
MICHALE FEE: Why
doesn't it keep going?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Why is there like a [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Ah.
Because-- OK.
That's a great question.
So maybe you can answer it.
How would I change
the conductance curve
to make this look
more like this?
I could do something very
simple to the voltage dependence
of the potassium
conductance to actually make
it look like that.
What would I do?
The reason this goes
to 0 and stays at 0
is because the voltage
dependence of the conductance
turns it off before the driving
potential can go negative.
So what would I do
to the conductance
to make this current dip
below 0 before it comes back,
any suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Translate it.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, which way?
AUDIENCE: This way.
MICHALE FEE: Good, exactly.
So if I took this curve
and I shifted it that way,
if I made the potassium
conductance turn off
at a more negative
potential, then this
would go down before it got
turned off by the conductance.
Does that make sense?
Great question.
Any other questions?
So the answer is, the reason
this doesn't go negative
is because the voltage
dependence of the potassium
conductance turns
off the conductance
before or on the positive
side of the equilibrium
potential of potassium.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
again why the [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: So if
G were constant,
if G had no voltage dependence
and it was just a constant,
what would this
current look like?
What would it look like?
If this G were just a constant,
no dependent on voltage?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
It would look just
like this, right?
So the reason this curve
shuts off and goes to 0
is that the conductance
goes to 0 down here,
and it's constant up here.
Does that make sense?
And that curve just
looks like that.
It's 0 down here and
constant up here.
Good question.
Any other?
There was another hand up here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering about notation.
So it's GK of V. It's not
like GK times V, right?
MICHALE FEE: No.
It's GK as a function
of V. Yeah, that's--
the notation is sometimes
a little bit confusing.
You kind of have to read
it out from the context.
Any other questions?
So now you can see why this
curve looks the way it does.
So now, let's plot the driving
potential, V minus Ena.
That's this curve right here.
It's Ohm's law, but it has a
battery that makes it centered.
It makes it give 0 current
when V is equal to Ena,
which is positive.
So that's why that
curve looks like that.
And what is it that
makes the sodium
current go to 0 down here?
It must be that the what?
What about the conductance?
AUDIENCE: Turns off.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
The conductance, the
sodium conductance,
has to turn off down here.
And what about up here?
This is linear.
This is linear, so
the sodium conductance
has to be what up here?
Constant, good.
So you can see that
the sodium conductance
has exactly the same shape
as the potassium conductance.
It's not exactly at the same
voltage, but it's close.
Good.
So now you can see
where this kind
of weird shape of these
sodium and potassium currents
comes from.
It's actually very simple.
It's just a resistor in series
with a battery that gives you
this driving potential
offset from 0,
and that's multiplied by this
voltage-dependent conductance.
Now, the time dependence
of the conductance
is entirely due-- sorry.
The time dependence
of the current,
that ramping up current
that turns on and then stays
constant for the
potassium, is entirely
due to the time dependence
of the potassium conductance.
So the potassium
conductance just turns on.
That process of the
conductance turning on
is called activation.
Same for the sodium--
the sodium conductance
turns on quickly.
That's called activation.
The sodium conductance
turns on very fast,
and the potassium
conductance turns on slowly.
Now, we talked about
how the voltage gates
work in our voltage-dependent
ion channel.
And the idea is that you
have some gating charges that
are literally charged
residues, charged amino acids,
in the protein.
When the membrane
potential is very negative,
when the cell is
at rest, you can
see that there's a large
electric field pointing
that way inside the membrane,
and that pushes the charges,
pushes those gating charges,
toward the inside of the cell,
and that closes the gate.
When you depolarize the
cell, this membrane potential
goes closer to 0, the
electric field drops,
and those gating
charges are no longer
being pushed into the cell.
And they relax back,
and the gate opens.
So that is the basic,
sort of a cartoon,
picture of the mechanism by
which voltage-dependent ion
channels acquire that
voltage dependence.
So remember, we
talked about how we
can model that time dependence.
We can model that
opened and closed
state of the ion channel as
two states, an open state
and a closed state, where
the probability, n, of being
in the open state, a
probability of 1 minus
n being in the closed state.
Remember, this was
for one subunit.
For the potassium channel,
there are four subunits,
and all of them have to be open.
And we wrote down a
differential equation
for that gating variable, n.
There is an n infinity,
a steady state,
that's a function of voltage.
And remember, for the
potassium, n infinity
is negative down
here and increases
as a function of voltage
to get close to 1
at voltages above minus 50,
or somewhere between minus 50
and 0 millivolts,
that gating variable.
And the n infinity of
that gating variable, n,
goes from being very
small to being large.
Now, so that's potassium.
We went through that last time.
And now let's talk about sodium.
Sodium looks exactly the same.
The sodium conductance
can be modeled
as having two states, an open
state and a closed state.
Remember, we did
a patch recording
on a single sodium channel.
You could see that it flickers
back and forth between open
and closed.
So we can model that process
in exactly the same way
that we did for the
potassium conductance.
We have an open state, a
closed state, a probability, m,
of being in the open state.
So m is our gating
variable for--
our activation gating variable
for the sodium conductance.
Probability of being in a
closed state is 1 minus m.
There is that same kind of
differential equation for the m
gating variable,
and a m infinity
that has a voltage
dependence that
looks very much like the voltage
dependence of n infinity.
So so far, the sodium and
potassium conductances
look very similar.
They both have the same kind
of activation gating variable,
the same simple model for
how to turn on and turn off,
same differential
equation, same gating
variable that has this
sigmoidal dependence on voltage.
Any questions about that?
So you remember
the way we thought
about the time
dependence of these
is we simply integrate
this differential
equation over time.
It's a first order linear
differential equation,
and you can think about
the n, the gating variable,
as always relaxing
exponentially toward whatever
n infinity is at that moment.
And n infinity is a
function of voltage,
and any time dependence
it gets comes
from changes in the voltage.
So we're going to simplify
things and just consider
piecewise constant
changes in the voltage.
So let's do a simple experiment.
We're going to hyperpolarize
the voltage to minus 80.
What is n infinity going
to be, big or small?
Remember what n infinity looks
like is a function of voltage?
AUDIENCE: Small.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
So at hyperpolarized voltages,
n infinity is going to be small,
and so is m infinity.
Those ion channels are closed
at hyperpolarize voltages.
So the gating variables
that represent
what the probability is of being
open, those gating variables
are small when the voltage
is negative, very negative.
So then we're going to
step the voltage up.
And what is n
infinity going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Anybody want
to just draw for me what
it's going to do in the air?
It starts out small.
So is it going to
ramp up slowly?
Is it going to jump up?
Is it going to wiggle around?
What's it going to do?
So why is it--
so I have several
different answers.
I have some people saying
that it's going to ramp up.
I'm asking about M
infinity now, not n.
So how many people say it's
going to jump up suddenly?
OK, good.
That's what it's going to do.
It's going to start
out at a small value
and jump up to a larger value
when you depolarize the cell.
And then what is n going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good. n is going to
start at some initial condition
and relax exponentially
toward n infinity.
And then when you turn
the voltage back down,
N infinity is going to
go from this large value
back down to a
small value, and n
is going to relax
exponentially to that smaller
value of n infinity.
Any questions about that?
We saw that last time.
Now, what is the
conductance going to do?
Where does the conductance
depend on n, anybody remember,
for potassium?
How many subunits are
there in a potassium?
AUDIENCE: Four.
MICHALE FEE: Four.
And so if the probability
that each one is open is n,
and there are four
independent, what's
the probability that they're
all going to be open?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
And so the conductance is going
to turn on as this relaxing
exponential to the fourth.
And it's going to have that
kind of gradual ramping up.
Good.
It looks exactly
the same for sodium.
So if you start hyperpolarized,
you depolarized the cell,
that m infinity is
going to start small,
it's going to jump
up to a high value.
M is going to start
small, and it's
going to relax exponentially
toward that higher
value of m infinity.
Now, anybody want to
guess at what the sodium
conductance will look like?
It's going to be some
function of m, right?
It turns out that it m cubed.
And the reason is
that even though there
are four things that
have to all be open,
they're not independent
of each other.
And so the exponent is not m
to the fourth, it's m cubed.
And Hodgkin and Huxley
figured that out simply
by plotting these
relaxing exponentials
to different powers.
I imagine them saying,
oh, the potassium is 4.
Let's take m to the 4.
But it didn't fit.
So they tried some other, and
they found that m cubed fits.
So that's it.
Now, the problem with
this model is what?
What is the problem
with this model?
Is that when you
depolarize the cell,
the potassium current turns on.
The potassium conductance turns
on, but then what happens?
What is-- sorry.
The sodium turns on.
What happens?
It doesn't do this.
It doesn't turn on
and stay on, right?
The potassium, when
you depolarize,
turns on and stays on,
just like that model.
But the sodium does
something else.
What does it do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's a voltage clamp.
MICHALE FEE: This
is voltage clamp,
so it's we're
controlling the voltage.
m is already a maximum here,
so it can't shoot up anymore,
right?
Anybody remember what sodium
does that's really weird?
AUDIENCE: Deactivation.
MICHALE FEE: It inactivates.
So the current turns on,
a conductance turns on,
but it doesn't stay on.
It turns off, and that's what
we're going to talk about next.
And once we have that, we've got
the whole Hodgkin-Huxley model.
And that'll set us up for
this really interesting sodium
channel defect that we're
going to talk about.
So that process
there of shutting off
is called inactivation.
This process of n turning
on is called activation.
n turning off is
called deactivation.
m turning on is
called activation.
m turning off is
called deactivation.
But this other thing
has a different name.
It's called inactivation.
It's kind of a little
tricky terminology.
So the potassium-- the
probability of the sodium
current being--
the sodium channel
being open actually
goes like m cubed times some
other gating variable that
describes how this turns off.
And so there's another
gating variable, called h.
It's called the inactivation
gating variable for sodium.
And so now we're going to
figure out how to think about h
and how to describe
it mathematically.
You probably wouldn't
be surprised to hear
that it's just another first
order linear differential
equation--
activation gating variable, m,
inactivation gating variable,
h.
So how do we think
about inactivation?
Inactivation is literally just
a little loop of goo or snot
on the inside of the sodium
channel, and it's charged.
And when the sodium
channel opens,
it just falls in and
plugs up that the pore.
That's it.
So when the membrane
potential is very negative,
the inside of the
cell is negative,
there's an electric
field pointing this way,
and the inactivation particle
is slightly positively charged.
And that pushes it,
keeps it out of the way.
It turns out that
that's a real thing.
It turns out it's just a loop
of amino acids on the inside
of the ion channel.
Hodgkin and Huxley,
of course, they
didn't have the structure
of the sodium channel,
but they actually predicted
the existence of this thing
that they called the
inactivation particle.
When you depolarize
the cell, when
the membrane potential inside
the cell goes more positive,
that positive
charge is no longer
actively kept out of the pore.
And so it falls in
and blocks the pore.
And that prevents
ions from flowing
through the ion channel.
So how would you model this?
There's an open state
and a closed state
with energy levels.
How would you want to do that?
AUDIENCE: Use the
Boltzmann distribution.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, you could
use the Boltzmann distribution
to compute the
voltage dependence.
I haven't done that, but I'm
sure it would work pretty well.
How would you model
the time dependence?
So let me ask you this.
If there is a gating variable--
let's start with this.
If there is a
gating variable, h,
that we're going to use to
describe this thing getting
open and closed, what is
the voltage dependence
of h infinity
going to look like?
When the voltage is very
negative, what is h doing?
You think it's big or small?
Here's the equation-- m cubed h.
So when the-- yeah, right. h has
to start out high and go small
in order to explain
this thing turning off.
Does that make sense?
So what we're going to do
is we're going to have--
we're going to model this again
with two states, an open state
and a closed state.
h is the probability
that this inactivation
particle is in the open state.
It turns out that there's
only one of these particles,
and so that explains
why it's just times h,
not times h to some power.
And we have a
differential equation
that describes how h changes
as a function of time
in a way that depends
on h infinity.
And Aditu, why don't you draw
what h infinity probably looks
like as a function of voltage.
AUDIENCE: High.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
It just starts
high and goes down.
How do we actually measure that?
Let me show you an experiment
how you'd measure that.
So first, let me
just show you this.
So when you depolarize the
cell, h starts out high,
because h infinity is high.
And then when you depolarize
the cell, h infinity gets small,
and h just relaxes exponentially
toward the new smaller h
infinity.
And what's really cool is that
the tail, this inactivation,
the way that conductance
or the current turns off,
is just a single exponential.
It just falls like E to the
minus some time constant.
It's just given by this first
order linear differential
equation.
Good.
This h getting smaller
is called inactivation.
Anybody want to take a guess
at what this is called?
AUDIENCE: Deinactivation.
MICHALE FEE:
Deinactivation, good.
So there's activation
and deactivation.
There's inactivation
and deinactivation.
Those are different things.
Just remember activation,
which is easy, right?
It's just things turning on.
And then there's
the same process
that undoes the turning on.
That's deactivation.
And there's inactivation,
which is a separate particle.
And it has a process of
blocking and unblocking.
So it's inactivation,
deinactivation.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If there
is any activation,
does that mean it's
already charged up?
So what does deactivation mean?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So when-- here.
Let's just go back
to this picture here.
When the cell is
hyperpolarized, the thing
is hanging out outside
not getting in the way.
When you depolarize the
cell, that electric field
is not pushing it out
anymore, and it falls in.
But when you hyperpolarize
the cell again,
that electric field
turns back on.
And what is it going to do?
It pushes the particle back
out to the other state,
to the open state.
Any other questions?
Pretty simple, right?
Kind of very machine-like.
And then what we're
going to talk about soon
is how this thing sometimes
doesn't work, this thing.
There are genetic
mutations that turn out
to be fairly common actually,
where this doesn't reliably
block the pore.
And we're going to
see what happens.
First order linear
differential equation.
Exponential relaxation
toward new h infinity.
We can actually
measure this h infinity
as a function of voltage by
doing the following experiment.
What we do is we hold
the cell hyperpolarize.
We can then step the cell up to
different membrane potentials--
very low or very high.
And then what we do is we
jump the membrane potential
up to turn on the
activation gating variable.
And now we can see--
what you see is, that
depending on where
you held the voltage before
you did this big voltage step,
you get sodium currents
of different size.
And you can guess that if you
hold the voltage very negative
and then turn it on,
that activation gating
variable for all those ion
channels is [AUDIO OUT]..
And when you turn
on the sodium--
turn on the gating
variable, you're
going to get a big
current, right?
If you hold the cell for a
while here at a higher voltage,
most of those
sodium channels are
going to have that inactivation
gate already closed.
And so now when you step
the voltage up, turn on m,
you're going to get a
much smaller current.
And so if you just
plot the current size
as a function of this
holding potential,
you can see that h is
big for low voltages
and goes to 0 for
higher voltages.
And what this means is
that when a cell spikes,
that voltage goes up, and h
starts falling, and the sodium
channels--
many of the sodium
channels in the cell
becomes inactivated--
become inactivated.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The membrane
potential on the x-axis,
is that the difference in the--
is that [AUDIO OUT] or is that
the [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: That's the absolute
voltage during this holding.
That's right.
You can actually see at
rest most cells actually
have a substantial fraction
of the sodium channels
already inactivated.
So here's the plan.
We now have a full
description of the potassium
and the sodium conductances as
a function of voltage and time.
So we're to put it
all together and make
a full quantitative description
of the Hodgkin-Huxley model.
Our probability of the sodium
current, sodium channel,
being open is m cubed h.
I just want to mention
that this m cubed
h assumes one thing
about the gating variable
and the inactivation variable.
The mechanism for activation and
the mechanism for inactivation
assumes what about them?
AUDIENCE: They're independent.
MICHALE FEE:
They're independent.
And it turns out that
that's not quite true.
It's one of the very few
things that Hodgkin and Huxley
didn't get spot-on.
So it's not exactly independent,
but it's really not bad either.
So it's a pretty-- it's
still a pretty good model.
We can write down the
sodium conductance
as just the conductance
of the sodium channel
when it's all the way
open times m cubed h.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So do we know what
the inactivation particle is?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
We're going to see in a second.
I'll show you exactly
what it looks like
and where these
mutations are that have
this effect on inactivation.
So we can write down
the conductance,
and we can write
down the current.
The current is just
the open conductance
times m cubed h times
the driving potential.
And that's our sodium current.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For the
[INAUDIBLE],, I'm
not showing there is
[INAUDIBLE] like a number,
like sodium channel
or something.
It doesn't have it.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, that's right.
It's one, one single protein,
but it has these transmembrane
alpha-helices that act--
are multiple voltage sensors.
And they act somewhat
independently, but still
a little bit
cooperatively, and that's
where this m cubed comes from.
But you're right.
The potassium channel actually
has four separate subunits
that form a tetramer.
The sodium channel [AUDIO OUT]
that it's all one big protein.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
You should really
think of this--
I mean the n and
the m were both--
it was empirically
discovered that one
goes as n to the fourth, and
the other one goes as m cubed.
And it turns out
for potassium it
has a really beautiful
relation to the structure.
For sodium, it's a
little bit messier.
And I'm sure there are people
who actually understand more
about why it's exactly
m cubed, but I'm not
one of those people.
So I'm going to refer
you to the literature.
And I'm happy-- maybe I can
find a good reference for that.
So now that we have the sodium
conductance and the sodium
current, let's put
this all together.
So here's how we're
going to now--
here's the algorithm for
generating an action potential.
And we introduced
this last time,
but let's just flesh it
out for the full story.
So given an initial voltage,
compute n infinity, tau n,
m infinity, tau m, and
h infinity and tau h,
as a function of that voltage.
Those are just those
algebraic expressions
that give you the
alpha n and beta
n for each of those
things-- one for potassium,
one for sodium, the m, and
one for the h for sodium.
So we're going to
calculate all of those.
Steady state gating variables
as a function of voltage,
we're going to start from our
initial condition of n, m,
and h, and integrate that
differential equation one time
step using--
it's going to
relax exponentially
toward n infinity.
We're going to plug that n,
m, and h into our equations
for the potassium
current, sodium
current, and leak, which doesn't
have those gating variables.
So the potassium current is
Gn to the 4 times the driving
potential.
Sodium current is Gm cubed h
[AUDIO OUT] driving potential.
We're going to add
all of those currents
together to give the
total membrane current.
That membrane current
is going to give us
a V infinity for our cell.
Remember, the V infinity
is just the current times
the effective resistance.
So we can use that
to also calculate
the membrane time constant.
And then we integrate the
voltage one time step.
Go back and recompute those
n, m, and h infinities.
And then we just keep
cycling through this.
When you do that, and
you plot the voltage,
you get an action potential.
Now, you can do
that in a hundredth
of a second in MATLAB.
Hodgkin and Huxley we're doing
this on their slide rules,
and they got 2/3 of the way
through an action potential
and said, let's just publish.
[LAUGHTER]
So here's what that looks like.
Here's V as a function
of time for when you
implement that loop in MATLAB.
So you can see what you did.
So this is the injected
current through the electrode,
and can see it
starts to depolarize
the cell a little bit.
And at some point,
what happens is--
this is just a copy over here
so you can line things up--
when you inject current, the
cell starts to depolarize.
And you can see that
m starts to grow.
The sodium current is
starting to turn on.
And at some point,
m gets big enough
that it's turning on a
substantial amount of sodium
current into the cell.
And what does that do?
It depolarizes to cell more,
which causes m to grow faster,
which causes more current, which
depolarizes the cell faster.
And it just runs away-- bam--
until you reach
essentially the equilibrium
potential of sodium.
And then what does
the sodium current do?
The sodium current
actually stops
even though the channel's open.
Then what happens is, during
that whole time, n has,
in this hyperpolarized voltage--
the potassium channel is
starting to open and grows,
potassium current
conductance turns on,
and that starts
hyperpolerizing the cell.
During that whole time,
the inactivation gate--
this cell is very
depolarized, very positive.
That little bit of
goo falls in, h drops.
That shuts off the
sodium conductance.
Potassium conductance finishes
bringing the cell back.
Beautiful, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is h just
the voltage-dependent
or it's also time-dependent?
MICHALE FEE: Time-dependent
in exactly the same way
that n and m are time-dependent.
There is a-- h infinity
changes as a sum--
as a function of voltage.
And then h relaxes
exponentially toward h infinity.
Any questions about that?
So for the problem set,
you'll have code for this,
and you can play around with
this and try different things.
And then there's a
particular problem
that Daniel and I cooked
up for you for this.
I'll basically show you
what that looks like.
Here's the crux of it.
If you inject a
little bit of current
into the Hodgkin-Huxley
neuron, you get a spike.
And then if you wait
a few milliseconds
and inject another current
pulse, what happens?
You don't get a spike.
Can anybody guess why that is?
AUDIENCE: h is
still inactivated.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
That thing is still
stuck in there
and hasn't had time
to fall out yet.
And if you plot h, you can see
that it hasn't recovered back
to the state it was
at the beginning.
So that's called a
"refractory period."
So cells don't like to spike
two times in a row to close.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what things
like [INAUDIBLE] h at which
it's a spike?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So you want to just like--
what would be the
intuitive answer?
So there's not a
hard cutoff, right?
If h is right here, it
will be much harder.
You'd have to inject a lot
more current to make it spike.
If h is recovered
to here, then it
would take a little bit less
current to make it spike.
So basically, there's
a gradual decrease
in the amount of
current it would take
to make the neuron spike again.
So there's no one answer.
So let's take a
look at what happens
when sodium channels go bad.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Most of the animals
on this petting farm,
on Maui, Hawaii, are sweet,
but nothing too unusual.
And then there are the goats--
Myotonic goats, to be specific--
more commonly known
as stiff-legged goats,
wooden-leg goats, nervous
goats, fainting goats.
Fainting goats are
indigenous to North America.
But that name is a
bit of a misnomer,
because they never
lose consciousness
when they keel over.
If they're startled, a genetic
condition causes their muscles
to lock up.
But it only lasts a few
moments, and then they're
back on their feet.
Now, until the next
time they're spooked.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: So
these fainting goats
have a particular mutation
in their sodium channel.
Now, it turns out that
the sodium channels that
are in your brain that
control action potentials
are a different gene
than the sodium channels
that are in your muscles that
produce muscle contractions.
So you can have a mutation
in the skeletal isoform
of the sodium channel that
produces these muscular effects
without having any
effect on brain function.
But that same
mutation in the brain,
isoform of the sodium
channel, is lethal.
So this is actually a condition
that exists in humans.
It's called-- there are
actually a whole set of these,
what are called "sodium
channel myotonias."
One of them is called
hyperkalemic periodic
paralysis.
And this just
shows a different--
this is a different phenotype
of one of these sodium channel
defects.
So the goats became very
stiff and fell over.
It turns out there's a different
phenotype that looks like this.
So basically, it causes
extreme weakness.
The muscles are
completely paralyzed.
They can't contract
anymore, and it
seems like that would be a
completely different effect--
what would cause
muscles to just go
rigid and a very similar
thing would cause paralysis--
and it turns out that
actually those two things
have very similar cause.
That hyperkalemic-- kalemic
refers to potassium.
And so this condition is very
sensitive to potassium levels.
At high potassium
levels, it's much worse
than at low potassium levels.
So there can be an attack
of weakness or paralysis,
and then just a few minutes
later somebody's all better,
and that paralysis goes away.
So to understand what's
going on in this condition,
we need to take a look at how
muscle fibers actually work.
So let's take a
little detour in that.
So basically, let's start
here with the action potential
that drives muscle twitches.
So the way this works is
that it an action potential
will propagate down an axon
toward the neuromuscular
junction.
That action potential will cause
the release of neurotransmitter
that then causes current to
flow into the muscle fiber.
That current flowing
into the muscle fiber
depolarizes it, turns
on sodium channels,
and that causes an action
potential in the muscle fiber
that looks very much
like the action potential
that we just saw for a neuron
for the squid giant axon.
Now, there is this
famous problem,
called the "excitation
contraction coupling problem,"
which is, how does an
action potential here
on the surface of a muscle fiber
get down into the myofibril
and cause a contraction
of the muscle?
So we'll get to that
question, but let me just
describe what these things are.
So the myofibrils--
the myofibril
is this little element inside
of the muscle fiber itself.
And these are bundles of thick
fibers and thin fibers that
essentially--
here, I think it's
on the next slide.
So let me just finish the
story about how the action
potential gets inside.
So the action
potential propagates
through these little structures
called transverse tubules.
These are little tubes that go
from the surface of the muscle
fiber down into the muscle cell.
They're like axons.
But instead of going
out from the cell body,
they go into the cell body.
That's pretty cool.
This thing is huge.
This muscle fiber is
about 100 microns across.
So in order for that signal
to get into the myofibril
to cause contraction,
it actually
has to propagate
down an axon that
goes into the muscle fiber.
So that action potential
propagates down
into the t-tubules that's a
voltage pulse that opens up
voltage-dependent calcium
channels that activate
calcium release in
something called
the sarcoplasmic reticulum.
So you may remember
that in neurons
the endoplasmic reticulum
sequesters calcium.
In a muscle fiber, the
sarcoplasmic reticulum
does the same thing.
It's sequesters calcium.
But when this voltage
pulse comes down
the t-tubule, its
voltage-dependent calcium
channels, which cause
the release of calcium,
which then activates
calcium-dependent calcium
release through another
set of channels,
and it basically floods the
myofibrils with calcium.
And that triggers
the contraction.
And here's how that works.
Within these myofibrils are
bundles of thick filaments,
which are myosin and thin
filaments, which are actin.
The thick filaments are
these structures right here.
The actin are filaments,
thin filaments,
that intercalate between
the myosin thick filaments.
The myosin thick filaments
are covered with these myosin
molecules that stick out.
The myosin heads that are
like little feet reach out.
And if they bind
to the actin, then
these things basically grab the
actin and start walking along.
And they pull the actin.
They pull this actin
filament this way.
The ones over here
walk this direction
and pull this actin
filament that way,
and that causes these
two end plates to pull,
sorry, these two, what
are called "z disks,"
to pull together.
And the thing shortens.
Does that make sense?
And then when the
contraction stops,
these little feet stop walking.
They relax, and those
actin filaments now
can relax and retract.
Pretty cool, right?
So how does the calcium
connect to that?
So the calcium goes in,
floods this myofibril.
The calcium goes in and binds
to these little molecules,
called troponin, that are
sitting in grooves of the actin
filaments.
And when the calcium
binds to troponin,
it moves out of the
way and opens up
the binding site for
these myosin heads to grab
onto the actin filament.
They grab on and they pull.
And as soon as they
pull, an ATP comes off.
These things open
up, ATP binds, boom.
They pull again.
So they just walk along
with one ATP per cycle.
Then when the calcium--
what happens is that the calcium
starts being sequestered back
into the sarcoplasmic reticulum
that unbinds from the troponin.
The troponin falls
back into the groove,
and the myosin heads can no
longer connect to the actin.
And that's the end
of the muscle twitch.
Pretty amazing, right?
So what goes wrong when sodium
channels are inactivated?
And that's what we're going to
talk about next-- when sodium
channels fail to inactivate.
So here's what the sodium
channel looks like.
There are these clusters of
transmembrane alpha-helices.
These things together,
these four things together,
form the pore.
And there's a loop
between them here
that produces the inactivation.
And you can see, if
you look at the sights
of different mutations
of the sodium channel
that produce defective
inactivation,
they tend to be clustered
in these cytoplasmic loops
of the sodium channel.
So myotonia and the
periodic paralysis
that we just saw
in those movies are
caused by these different sets
of mutations on those loops.
And again, for these
myotonias, these mutations
are in the skeletal isoform
of the sodium channel.
So now, what do those
mutations actually do to this?
So now, let's take
a look at-- let's do
a patch clamp
experiment, where we take
muscle fiber from a wild-type.
So you can just take
a muscle biopsy--
extract a little
pinch of muscle.
You can culture it in a dish.
And you can do that for
wild-type, normal human muscle
fibers.
And you can do it
for muscle fibers
from a person with this
particular mutation
of this sodium channel.
And you can see that just
like for the neurons,
just like for the sodium
channels in neurons,
you can see that
depolarizing this ion channel
produces brief openings that
are aligned at the time when
you do the depolarization step.
And then there are
no more openings.
The sodium channels
turn on, and then
that gating variable,
that inactivation gate,
shuts off the pores, and
there are no more openings.
But in the muscle fiber
that has this mutation,
you can see that you get
this burst of openings right
at the time of depolarization,
but you keep getting openings
at later times.
And if you plot the average
current over many trials,
you can see in
normal fibers there's
this very brief
pulse of opening,
and in these fibers, muscle
fibers, with a mutation,
there is a constant extended
high probability of that sodium
channel turning on, opening up.
And that's what causes all
the problems right there.
In these conditions, that
only represents about a 2%,
a 0.02 probability,
of turning on
at a time when a normal muscle
fiber would be inactivated.
So you can actually study
these things in more detail.
So this shows a set of
experiments that were
done in rat fast twitch muscle.
This shows a control, and
this shows a muscle fiber
that's been treated with a
toxin that comes from the sea
anemone that produces a
toxin that uses this toxin
to actually help catch prey.
And it turns out,
what that toxin
does is it mimics the
effect of this blockage
of the inactivation
of the sodium channel.
So you can see that
applying this toxin
also produces these
extended openings
or failures to inactivate.
If you take that toxin and you
[AUDIO OUT] to a muscle fiber,
you see something
really interesting.
You take a muscle fiber.
You can hook it up to--
tie a string to one end, and
tie a string to the other end,
and kind pull it
tight a little bit,
and measure the force that
that muscle fiber is exerting.
So you can measure force
as a function of time.
If you stimulate
that muscle fiber
with a little
electrical shock, you
can elicit what's
called a muscle twitch.
And in the presence
of this ATXII toxin,
you can see that that twitch
is very extended in time.
Is there a question?
Did I see a hand?
No.
So what's going on?
So you can now record
from this muscle fiber
when it's been treated with
this toxin that produces
what's called a myotonic run.
And you can see that [AUDIO OUT]
muscle fiber produces
a single or maybe two action
potentials when depolarize it.
That's what a muscle
fiber normally does.
But when you treat
it with this ATXII,
it generates many
action potentials.
Now, why would that be?
Does that make sense?
We're going to
explore why that is.
We're going to look at
a particular model for
how the sodium--
the failure to inactivate
of the sodium channel
produces these myotonic runs.
What's really crazy is
that after you turn off
that current injection that
activates the muscle fiber,
the neuron keeps spiking.
The muscle fiber keeps spiking.
That continued
spiking corresponds
to continued contraction
of the muscle.
So you can trigger the muscle
to generate some action
potentials in a
normal muscle that
produces a very brief twitch.
But in these muscles with
this mutated sodium channel--
in this case it's
with the toxin,
but the same thing happens
in the muscle fibers with
the mutated sodium channel--
it produces continued
contraction of the muscle.
And that's what was
happening to the goats.
Their muscles contracted,
and then they didn't relax.
And so they were stiff like
this, and then they fall over.
Now, that's called
a myotonic run.
It's really interesting
and was a big clue
to what the mechanism
is that produces this.
If you take these muscle
fibers and you put them
into a solution that doesn't
have the right osmolarity--
so too much, two too many
ions, too high an osmolarity,
or too low an osmolarity, just
like pure water, for example--
produces what's called
an osmotic shock.
And what it does is it
breaks all the t-tubules
from the membrane.
So it doesn't
break the membrane,
but it disconnects all the
t-tubules from the membrane.
Now, what happens is you see
the myotonic run goes away.
So something about the t-tubules
is causing this myotonic run.
So there's a really beautiful
set of papers from David Corey
and a person named Cannon, who
proposed a hypothesis for why
this actually happens, and I'll
walk you through the hypothesis
right now.
So here's the idea.
So when you have an
input from a motor neuron
onto the muscle fiber you get
synaptic input, [AUDIO OUT]
muscle fibers.
So this is the motor
neuron synapse.
That's the muscle fiber.
So you should think about this
as being a very long cell here,
and here's a t-tubule that's
represented by a channel coming
in from the surface.
So this is a cross-section
of the muscle fiber.
So the idea is that
that current injection
causes an action potential,
which causes sodium
to flow into the cell.
And on the hyperpolarize
phase of the action potential,
potassium goes out of the
cell to bring the cell back
down to a negative voltage.
Now, that actual potential
propagates into the t-tubule,
which means you're
going to have sodium
flowing into the cell
and potassium flowing out
of the cell.
But out of the cell means
into the t-tubule, right?
So what normally happens is,
after an action potential,
you're left with an excess
of potassium in the t-tubule.
So what happens-- think is
going to happen, anybody?
Think back to the first lecture.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
there's going to be
some pumping going on here.
But actually, most
of the potassium
gets out of the t-tubule
by a different mechanism.
It gets out by diffusion.
So these extra potassium
ions diffuse out
through that t-tubule back
into the extracellular space.
Now, can we estimate how
long it takes that to happen?
Any idea how we would do that?
Anybody want to take a guess?
Does anyone remember
how long it takes an ion
to diffuse across, let's
say, a cell body, 10 microns?
Kind of a few tens
of milliseconds,
right, 50 milliseconds?
This thing is about
25 microns long.
And so it will be
maybe four times that.
So that timescale
we can calculate
by just using our equation
for the relation between time
and distance for a
diffusion, and you
find that that's about
300 to 400 milliseconds.
So that's how long it
takes those potassium ions
to diffuse out of the t-tubule.
Now, what happens
when we have a sodium
ion that isn't inactivating?
What happens is you're going
to get a lot more spikes.
You're going to get a lot
more spikes generated,
because this sodium
current turns on,
but now it's not
properly inactivating.
And so you're going
to get extra spikes.
And those failure to enact
[AUDIO OUT] extra spikes,
and extra spikes
means you're going
to have a lot more potassium
going into the t-tubule.
So what is all that--
and remember, we now have
300 or 400 milliseconds
before that potassium can
get out of the t-tubule
by diffusion.
So what's going
to happen when you
have all that extra
potassium in the t-tubule?
What's it going to do?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: It corrects the
muscle fiber [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So remember, the
equilibrium potential,
the negative
equilibrium potential
of the muscle fiber, which
is normally, like any cell,
is down around minus 80,
that negative potential
is caused because
there's so much more
potassium inside the cell
than outside the cell.
And so the potassium
ions are normally
kind of leaking out of
a cell, and that keeps
the membrane potential low.
But now, if you--
remember, this is
outside the cell.
So you have now, suddenly,
a very high concentration
of potassium ions
outside the cell.
And what do they do?
They push their way back in.
They start diffusing back in,
which does what to the cell?
You now have
potassium ions going
the wrong way, which does what?
I think you already
gave the answer.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Depolarizes it.
MICHALE FEE:
Depolarizes the cell.
Puts potassium back in, and
it depolarizes the cell.
And what is that going to do?
AUDIENCE: Cause more spikes.
MICHALE FEE: Cause more spikes,
which is going to do what?
Push more potassium
into the t-tubule.
It's runaway instability.
So that's kind of a
cool hypothesis, right?
You could imagine all sorts
of experiments to test this.
Like you could put a little
thing in there to measure
potassium concentration
in the t-tubule.
Well, that's only a
few microns across.
How do you test this hypothesis?
How would you--
it's a great idea.
But how do you know if it even
makes any sense when you put it
all together, any suggestions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the potassium.
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
So it's already known
that at low potassium
this problem is less severe.
The disease is even named after
that observation-- hyperkalemic
periodic paralysis.
Any other suggestions?
What are we here for?
What is this class?
Introduction to neural
computation, right?
So what can we do?
This is a word model, right?
When you actually
put it all together,
you could do all this,
and when you model it,
it makes no sense whatsoever.
There's something wrong
with this word model.
Neuroscience is
full of word models.
The only way to know if a
word model makes any sense
is to actually write
down some equations
and see if it works the way
you think it is going to work.
See if your word model
translates into math.
And so that's what David
Corey and Cannon did.
They took this picture,
and they developed a model
for what that looks like it.
And it started with just
the Hodgkin-Huxley model.
Here's Hodgkin-Huxley.
That's what we've
been using all along.
They added another
little compartment
that represents the conductances
and the batteries associated
with the membrane
in the t-tubule.
And notice, there's a EK here.
What does EK depend on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Say it again.
EK depends on--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Of--
AUDIENCE: Potassium.
MICHALE FEE: Of potassium
ions, and potassium
ions are changing.
So let's actually-- so
this part you already know.
That's just Hodgkin and Huxley
with a few extra resistors
attached to the side of it.
What about the potassium part?
Let's just flesh out that
model a little bit more
to see how spiking activity
would lead to changes
in potassium, how that
change in potassium
would change the
battery, and how
that would feedback and
change the spiking activity.
So let's do that.
So we're going to
imagine that we
are going to model our
potassium conductance in here.
So we're going to write
down a variable that's
the potassium concentration
inside the t-tubule.
And what is going to affect
that potassium concentration?
What are the sources
of potassium?
What are the sinks of
potassium, anybody?
Well, one is just diffusion.
So we can model that, and that
looks an awful lot, actually,
like Fick's first law.
So the change in
potassium concentration
as a function of time
has a contribution
from the difference between
the potassium concentration
inside and outside.
That rate of change
through diffusion
is proportional to the
difference in concentration
inside and outside divided
by that time constant
that we've just calculated.
Now, what-- so that's
how potassium leaves.
That's one way that
potassium leaves.
So the potassium gets
into the t-tubule
at a rate that's just
proportional to the potassium
current.
The rate of change of the
potassium concentration
is proportional to
the potassium current.
And the potassium current--
so let's just flesh this
out a little bit more.
This, we already calculated.
This is the conductance
times the driving potential.
But that current, we have to
do a little bit of changes
of units to get
current into the right
units for a change in
potassium concentration
as a function of time.
So current is
coulombs per second,
and here we have moles
per liter per second.
So we need to divide
by two things.
We need the volume
of the t-tubule,
and we need Faraday's
constant, which
is just coulombs per mole.
That's a well-known number
that you can just look up.
Multiply those two
things together,
you get the contribution
of the potassium current
to the rate of change of
potassium concentration.
The potassium current is
just conductance times
driving potential.
Notice the EK is a function
of potassium concentration.
I haven't written it in
here, but that's just
the Nernst potential.
And so we have a
differential equation
for the potassium concentration
as a function of time.
It's a function of the
potassium concentration voltage
and equilibrium potential.
And now, we just take that
and add it to the code
that we already have
for Hodgkin and Huxley.
And here's what you get.
So here's a normal muscle fiber.
You get a single
action potential.
What they did was they modeled--
they made some fraction
of those ion channels
fail to inactivate.
And here's what
happens to the model
when you make 2% sodium
channels fail to inactivate.
You see that you get this large
number of action potentials,
because the sodium channels
are not inactivating properly.
And when you turn
the current off,
you get this high
potassium concentration
in the t-tubule that's now
causing additional spikes.
That is continued
contraction of the muscle.
That is this myotonia.
The model is
exhibiting myotonia.
How do you explain
periodic paralysis?
That's totally different, right?
Now the muscle just
goes completely limp.
How do you do that?
Any thoughts about this?
What do you think
would happen if we
made a slightly larger
fraction of the sodium channels
fail to inactivate?
Here's what happens.
You get more and more
action potentials.
And at some point, what happens
is the voltage just locks up.
The sodium channels go
into a different state
where the system is
no longer oscillating.
It's just fixed
at a high voltage.
It's called
depolarization block,
and it's what happens when
there's no longer enough--
there aren't enough
sodium channels
active to give you
spiking, but there
are enough non-inactivated
sodium channels to just hold
the voltage high.
And this muscle fiber is
no longer able to contract,
and it's completely flaccid.
It's completely loose.
And so this is the hyperkalemic
periodic paralysis.
So you get both of these
really interesting phenotypes
in this disease just depending
on one little parameter, which
is what fraction of
these sodium channels
are failing to inactivate.
And so you can see, you get
this very complex phenotype
from a simple mutation
of an ion channel.
And in order to understand
really how it's behaving,
you have to do
modeling like this.
It's the way you understand
a system and how it works.
Until you do this, you
don't really understand it.
So I'll leave it there.
Thank you.